what would your advice be for someone
who wants to stop their medications and
try diet number one please don't stop
your meds on your own cold turkey not
because I don't want people to get off
their meds but I want to do it in a safe
way I usually don't touch their meds
initially I start the diet I make sure
they can do the diet and I make sure
that we start to see some benefits from
the diet and again that can be three or
four months for some people I also want
to make sure that the person can
actually do the diet and stick with it
but along the way I'm going to add other
things so I'm going to look at other
substances that they might be using that
might be causing problems and we might
be getting rid of those substances I'm
going to look at sleep and make sure
people are getting good restful sleep
might look at light exposure maybe we're
going to look at exercise so we're going
to look at a comprehensive treatment
plan and usually once they're off all
their meds and they're doing these
things that's when I see dramatic full
lasting recoveries